[Applause]
and finally new rule if you become the
opposite of what you always were you
have to change your name
it's become a trend in america these
days morphing into something completely
different from what you were founded as
but still pretending you're the old you
tlc stands for the learning channel
they used to have shows like learn to
read and ready set learn
here's some of their presents and recent
offerings
cake boss gypsy sisters toddlers and
tierras extreme couponing what not to
wear my teen is pregnant and so am i
thousand pound sisters and alaskan women
looking for love and that's just the
shows about the palin's
the a in a and e stands for arts
seriously they used to show the symphony
now they have deep fried dynasty
hoarders storage wars ghost hunters and
psychic kids
you know for people who find the
learning channel too intellectual
the uh history channel has no history
and mtv has no music i'm just saying you
can buy a petting zoo and turn it into a
bondage dungeon but you got to change
the sign
for decades playboy was the go-to
whack-off magazine
for heterosexual men with reviews of
movies that came out six months ago and
a lot of information about stereos
and fiction by kurt vonnegut
[Laughter]
but mostly the masturbation thing
which was facilitated by pictures of
naked women
who were naked
well in 2016 playboy did away with the
nudity
they took the tits out of
playboy
it's like taking the cats out of cat
fancy
last year playboy put a gay man on the
cover which i guess we're supposed to
celebrate even though it was 20 21 and
there's already a dozen magazines for
gay guys 13 if you count martha stewart
living
do we really need lgbt representation in
playboy
there's a transgender teenager on every
show on television except re-runs a
voyage to the bottom of the sea
the same thing is going on with the
sports illustrated swimsuit issue which
now celebrates all kinds of bodies
except you know the good kind
[Applause]
was it really such a crime against
humanity to have one magazine once a
year that was about finding creative
ways for supermodels to hide their
nipples
now it looks like it's edited by the
huffington post
geez you have every other magazine
do you hate dad that much
if he can't rub one out in the garage
what is he supposed to do in there
actually sand something
[Applause]
this is not progress you haven't
reformed the soft-core gentleman
masturbator you've driven them to
creepyporn.com
or how about
valentine's day which was always a day
to celebrate coupledom
it wasn't complicated flowers chocolates
blow job
and yet every year now i more and more
hear this idea that valentine's day is
also a day to celebrate being alone be
your own valentine
that's right on the one day we
specifically set aside to honor bonding
between two people
don't do that
make it about the opposite of that be
your own valentine get your own cheap
stale chocolates at cbs
you don't even need to have sex with
someone else you can go [ __ ] yourself
um
the boy scouts of america used to be an
organization for boys because girls have
cooties
but now the boy scouts accept girls
which i guess is inclusive but it
ignores the very important need for boys
to sometimes get together as boys to
fart in a sleeping bag
and laugh at that which girls don't find
funny
it also ignores the fact that there has
always also been a scout troop for girls
you may have heard of it the girl scouts
can't anything just be what it is
anymore
weight watchers used to be a club for
people to lose weight back when that was
a good thing
now we're so through the looking glass
that obesity the absolute undeniable
number one cause for ill health and
death in america is called
body positivity
and people are shamed for losing weight
it happened to adele
weight watchers is so intimidated they
changed their name to ww
why not just call yourselves wait wait
don't tell me
[Applause]
the aclu
has long been synonymous with freedom of
speech they defended it from even the
most hated groups like the nazis the
clan even the jehovah witnesses
it was never about what you were saying
it was about the liberal principle of
your right to say it
well they have new guidelines now namely
that before taking a case acl lawyers
should consider if the case might cause
offense to marginalized groups
or if a potential client's values are
contrary to our values
contrary to our values your values are
free speech and the first amendment
those are your values your whole purpose
in life is not to be worried about
offense to marginalized groups because
we understand that free speech
is an even more important value than
never being offended
[Music]
because you're the aclu not ucla
and finally there's the republican party
it used to stand for something being
heartless squares but something
oh and patriotism
they always wanted you to know they
loved america more than you
america first love it or leave it flag
pin in the lapel thank you for your
service america
but now tucker carlson is literally
reciting russian talking points
becoming so valuable to the kremlin that
they put out a memo asking their
propaganda outlets to replay as much of
tucker carlson as possible in russia
after the capitol riot on january 6th
147 republican lawmakers in a
congressional vote objected to the
certification of an election they knew
was legitimate
okay you can't be the super patriots who
love america and also run on a platform
of let's ignore the vote
you can't represent a form of government
you yourself don't believe in
if you do then you have to get another
name
like maybe the trump party
he's pretty modest about putting his
name on things but maybe he'll license
it just this once
you